-Our next guest is
a legendary award-winning
best-selling comic-book writer.
Their debut novel, "Luda,"
is out now.
Please welcome back to the show
one of our favorites,
Grant Morrison, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome back
to the show, Grant.
-Thanks for inviting me back.
It's great to be here again.
-I'm thrilled to have you.
I want to talk
about your writing.
I also want to take
this opportunity.
Obviously a very sad day,
you being Scottish.
Are you processing --
How are you processing
the passing of Queen Elizabeth?
-I heard about it just like
an hour ago, and it's kind of --
It's going to be
a major existential shock
for our country.
But for me,
it's the passing of an age.
That was the second
Elizabethan age.
We had the explosion
of creativity
that gave us the Beatles
and Brit rock
and British artists
and British writers.
And I think
it's just really weird.
That's the end of that now.
It's like the Shakespearean age
is over, you know,
except it's now,
so it's a weird one.
We Scots have a complicated
relationship with the monarchy,
so it's an interesting one,
I think, a bit.
-Yeah, I think it will take
all of us a bit of time.
The loss of a constant
is a very shocking thing.
-Yeah, absolutely.
-When there's so much upheaval,
you realize, oh, that was --
the length of time.
-And I think they should
just jump to the kid, honestly.
[ Laughter ]
-Now we're getting
to the nitty-gritty.
-The serious stuff. You know?
-So, you're beloved. You're
a well-known comic-book writer.
And, yet, this is
your first novel.
What was, one, the decision
to write the novel?
And, two, how different
was the process?
-Well, basically, my agent
came to me and said,
"Do you want to write a novel?"
And I've never managed
to do one.
Because I like
books with pictures.
You know, I'm basic like that.
And so if it hasn't
got a drawing,
then I'm not interested.
But I kind of figured,
that was the difference.
You know, I wasn't working with
a collaborator this time.
I'm used to having an artist.
Or if I worked on television,
as you know,
there's producers,
there's writers rooms.
It's a big thing.
It's like being in a band
or being in a football team.
So it was weird
to just be sitting on my own
and I had to make
the pictures into words.
And that was fun
because COVID had happened.
So there's nowhere to go.
I was kind of stuck in the room.
And a book came out of it.
It would never happened
but for the virus.
-Don't brag that up too much.
-No, certainly.
-Those people were like,
"Did you write a book, too?"
It's like, "No."
-I think most people tried.
-Most tried.
Well, it's very impressive
that you got it done.
This is a story
about an aging drag queen
and a younger sort of prodigy
who comes into their life
and how it affects it.
Where did this --
the seed of that idea come from?
-The idea came from --
I wanted to do a retelling
of the old story of
Merlin the magician,
the Arthurian legend.
And he had this story where
Merlin at the end of his life,
he meets this young witch
called Vivian.
And she flatters him and she
kind of wants to learn magic.
And, of course,
it all goes badly.
You know, he's just the old goat
who thinks
this beautiful young woman
is interested in him.
And he teaches her
all the secrets,
and then she locks him in
an oak tree for all eternity.
So a lesson for us all, I think.
-Don't trust the young.
-Yeah, do not trust the young,
especially the young
who want to learn your secrets.
So it started from that.
And I thought that's a story
that really needs
a drag makeover.
I want to see Merlin in a dress.
So the idea of doing
a contemporary version of that
and set in this theater
world that was super-contained
with these characters who were
basically living in a world,
which is our world, where we
can't tell the difference
between reality
and illusion anymore.
We're in the world of fake news
and VR and AR, all that stuff.
So this book is kind of,
how do you negotiate
what we don't know what's real
and what's true
and what's fake?
-To some degree,
it seems like drag
is a huge departure
from, say, superheroes.
But in another way,
it's not at all.
-Well, absolutely.
You think of Superman,
Peter Parker,
those are just nerdy guys,
but then they dress up in these
super flamboyant costumes
and go out at night?
Batman's the worst.
Batman's dressed
for the fetish club.
He gets in his big car,
and he cruises
the streets of Gotham.
He's obviously -- He's hoping
the Joker notices.
You know, he wants that.
He wants to be seen.
Laughter ]
And that's why.
There's no way he's going out
as Bruce Wayne.
That guy's putting on
the ears...and the cape
and is like, "Notice me!"
So I think it's just
a hop, skip, and a jump
from RuPaul to Bruce Wayne,
you know?
-And with each passing day,
RuPaul almost has as much money
as Bruce Wayne, so that --
It's getting closer.
-Yeah, and I know
she fights crime on the side.
-Yeah. And you --
Do you feel like you've had
your own experiences with drag?
-Absolutely.
When I was 11 years old,
it kind of started for me.
And I remember
there was this British comic
and there was this character
called Danny Merlin,
son of the wise.
And the guy was a magician,
this boy magician.
Harry Potter for weird dudes.
And he wore
this mini-toga thing.
It was a really unusual costume.
Bare legs and a pair of sandals.
So I thought,
"I'll dress up as this guy."
I love the adventures
of Danny Merlin.
So, I get dressed up
to be this boy magician,
got myself in a vest,
pulled it down, got my --
Mom's belt on.
And then I looked in the mirror
and I thought,
"Holy...you look great."
[ Laughter ]
And I thought, "My God,
I look like one of these models
in the 'Vogue' magazines
my mom's got lying about."
So it kind of messed
with my head.
And in that moment,
drag, comics, and magic
all hit me like a lightning bolt
and came about through this.
Yeah, I did that
for years on and off.
I was interested in performance
more than anything to do
with gender or sexuality.
It was all about performance
and letting loose
all these different characters
that I felt was inside.
-This book takes place
in "Gasglow,"
which is a version --
I guess sort of
a different universe version
of Glasgow, where you're from.
-Yeah.
-Have you had that name,
that version of
Glasgow in your head forever?
Because it's almost too good
to be true.
-Yeah, I didn't have the name,
but I had this version --
I had a dream
where there was a giant map
of a much bigger version
of the city,
and it was the city
that I visit in dreams.
You know, I think a lot of us
have got a version of a hometown
or a city
that we go to in dreams
and it's got places
that once existed
or places that don't exist.
But it was pretty consistent
for me.
And out of that came
the notion of Gasglow.
But it was a combination
of my hometown
and Glasgow and Brooklyn,
because they're really similar.
You know,
when I got to New York,
it was like -- this is like
Glasgow but gigantic.
Because Glasgow's
got the grid systems
and it's got the kind of energy
and the violence.
And every band in Glasgow
used to want to be --
They all wanted to be
the Velvet Underground.
So New York was kind of
a big influence.
So Gasglow is really --
it's why the character
talks in both British
and American idioms.
Because I wanted to
smash those two together
and kind of create this -- as
you say -- a kind of dream city
that combined elements of both.
-You dabbled in some punk music
back in the day.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
-Were you -- How did it go?
-It went pretty well.
We had a pretty good band.
But we all fell out in the end
because, you know,
bands always fall out.
And then there's a little bit
of that in the book, as well,
looking at the mad dynamics
that happen
in a group of people.
But, yeah, we had a good time.
We were psychedelic punks.
That's what we thought
of ourselves.
We were really into punk music,
but we loved to dress
like the Rolling Stones
and doing all this
kind of flamboyant frock coats
and feathers
and stuff like that.
So we would play
this crazy fast music.
But we were part
of the whole scene
that became Creation Records
and Alan McGee
with The Jesus and Mary chain
and Primal Scream.
So we used to support those guys
and we knew them pretty well.
-That must've been
a fascinating time to be there.
-Yeah, it was
a kind of wild time.
And so much of that influenced
things like Nirvana.
And, you know, they were
really influenced by those
Glasgow indie bands of the time.
-Now, you know, obviously,
music is in the rear view
and you've become this
sort of authority on comics.
And I have heard that people
often ask you questions
about comic-book superheroes
that maybe you weren't
prepared to answer.
-Well, always, you know, people
have got these wild ideas.
It's like they want to know
because the kids
who are into this stuff,
they take it super seriously.
So they want to know who pumps
the tires in the Batmobile.
Surely it's not him.
Does Alfred do it?
You know, Alfred's too busy
making sandwiches.
So who the hell
is pumping the tires?
Who's putting the gas
in the Batmobile?
It doesn't pull up to a station
like, "Yeah, just fill it up."
So, questions like that.
And the one I loved most was,
does Superman eat?
Because -- Does he have to eat?
Superman.
He's invulnerable.
He can do anything.
Surely, he doesn't have to eat.
And I'm having to think
of this question.
And I spoke to the kid,
and I said,
"I think he does eat,
but he's Superman,
so he takes every iota of energy
from anything he eats
so there's no waste product."
And then the guy says, "So,
he doesn't go to the bathroom?
So does it seal up then
over time?"
And I'm like,
"You're leading me into a place
I just don't want to go."
I'm thinking of
Superman flying through the air
with his ass sealing up?
I mean, give me a break here.
So, questions like that.
And the worst ones are,
"Can you explain the universe
and God to me?"
People have been
trying to do this
for the last 6,000 years
of human history,
and you've come to me?
This preposterous figure
in a blue suit
and asking me about God
and the universe?
But I always try, and
I always give them an answer
that I hope maybe
will send them away
with a prayer in their heart
and a song in their head.
-That's very sweet.
Another really sweet thing --
And I just did this for my son
because he wrote,
you know, drawings
of Green Lantern and Aquaman,
and we always
staple it together.
But your mom went and printed
your first comics.
-She did, yeah.
She used to take them into
the office and print them out
on one of those
super old-school photo copiers
where everything was faded
by the time
they got to the last page.
-Yeah.
-And she would do --
just churn these things out.
And her friends at work
just used to be,
"What the hell is this?
You should be working.
You shouldn't be doing this."
But yeah, she would do,
like, 300 copies
of some ridiculous story
that I'd done.
And then I could take them in
and they looked --
...I'm really published.
"No, actually, my mom
printed it up last night."
-We should all be so lucky
to have that support system.
And thanks for being here.
-It's always great
to talk to you.
-Grant Morrison.
"Luda" is out now.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."